this is the hercules beetle one of the  largest insects on earth  [Music]  the hercules beetle is named for its  incredible strength it can lift and  carry loads 850 times heavier than its  own weight  the most distinguishing characteristic  of the hercules beetle is the horn-like  pincers on its head  only male beetles have this intimidating  feature and it is used as a formidable  weapon in the battle for mating rights  the horns are usually about a third of  their body length but have been known to  grow even longer  hercules beetles are found in central  and south america and in the west indies  and feed predominantly on rotting wood  as larvae and fruit as adults  in spite of its strength and size the  hercules beetle is a threatened species  in many countries  much of its natural habitat has been  lost to deforestation and its  populations are suffering  this is the hercules beetle  [Music]  you